[Music]
thank you
yeah and how did you get through it my
mom passing away from breast cancer
heroin addiction
I got five months clean and sober right
now and just doing recovery thing and
twelve steps have a sponsor and just
staying away from the things I know
shouldn't be doing
now it's okay
just learning to accept it talk about it
it's been a long time it's been
14 years now what so you know but just
learning to remember her and think about
her but
remembering what she wanted for him try
to look that
I was always very like I mean just
conservative you know straight edge of
my mom was very like
you know she just didn't care what
people thought she didn't feel like she
had to live within you know certain
expectations she just a free spirit
that's the word I'm looking for
whereas though I was very like by the
book and so I try to look please fairy
tale so this is kind of personal but
I've always been kind of different so
there have been like times when I was in
a group and like they wouldn't let me in
and I just got through it like being
myself I never like went with them I
never like left something of myself just
to be like on another person for me
personally my mind's been my biggest
obstacle and I'm not through it but I
get through it every day by just
auditioning divorce yeah what
support them all on my own
still going through it I would say
reaching my fullest potential
where I feel I should be at when I was a
sixth grade I got hit by a car had to be
life-flighted to a hospital and that was
definitely scary and just the recovery
process of that that broken broken bones
scars just rehab stuff like that that
was probably most traumatic biggest
obstacle
coming out to my parents and I wrote it
on a ello sticky pad and put it on the
fridge door not being told enough and
high heels the biggest obstacle that I
had to get through was
getting sober about eight years ago and
I think what helped me get through it
the most was the support of family and
friends I don't
ah [ __ ] that's a good question
[Music]
it's when my best friend died in high
school and a plane crash and the way I
got through it was to continuously live
on his tree but he wished he could have
had the self-doubt that's been my
business biggest obstacle and you have
to believe in yourself and never confuse
confidence with cockiness they're not
the same
biggest obstacle of the
like a domestic violence situation where
shut up in hospitals
how did I get through it family even
with my son you know just knowing I have
to get through it
really just try to get established and
just stay well-rounded with everything
that's going on it's a constant obstacle
it really is
out here so for the last years I've been
trying to find out what I want to do
with my life that's a really big
obstacle and I did a really big trip to
find out and after seven months I don't
have any answer so I hope hey
my wife have you seen how she goes what
everything very optimistic me more
realistic it just just helped me open my
mind to believe that the greater who
come through no matter what one what you
going to a romantic relationship
how'd you get through a habit figuring
out what I'm missing and solving it I'm
in the process of fixing it's an ongoing
thing people don't people don't like
races to like you know maybe different
kind of races just because you're
different if I'm a mexican-american or
like latin-american really I
[ __ ] [ __ ] with me even though I
don't speak Spanish
they still [ __ ] with me so it's kind of
funny
had depression for a few years but
coming here starting new I I joined this
wilderness guiding program at UCSD and
the help has helped me a lot I mean my
biggest obstacle was letting loose a
little bit not being so tough on myself
all the time and I got over it by just
meeting really cool people who like
succeed in life while still enjoying in
life probably being comfortable at the
person that I am and then being
comfortable to share that with others
when I had beliefs allow for again 1999
finding a job over in the United States
was probably my biggest obstacle my mom
had an aneurysm when I was 17 it has
been stood in the back and we had to
take care of her and her because I'm the
young oldest sister so I'd take
responsibility financially I had some
responsibilities also it's like the
household things while she owes
recuperating but she's fine we're trying
to figure out what I wanted to do in
life and
criticals I wanted to achieve
how I
that was by interning and kind of
figuring out what route I wanted to go
in
probably just bouncing happiness and
what I want to do the rest my life I
think my biggest obstacle is I've been
dealing with a lot of injuries like in
football right now and other sports and
I just think it's very like by going to
the gym and just trying to exercise as
much as I can and work it out to build
my muscle back to be honest like
inverted question I don't really know
but I would have to say that the dad of
my grandfather
hard time but with the help of my
parents are my
friends I like get to I guess being on
my own like living on my own I guess
didn't big or growing up on my own like
I guess how old are you 18
since I was 13
how'd you get through well I always knew
there was you know like people say it's
not always going around on the other
side but I knew it had to be for me so I
know how to get
[Music]